as war in ukraine escalates there are
fears amongst international leaders that
vladimir putin is preparing to deploy
chemical weapons so what are they
chemical weapons are considered weapons
of mass destruction they are toxic
chemicals that can cause death injury
incapacitation or sensory irritation
chemical weapons are categorized by the
effect they have on the human body nerve
agents like novichok stop people's
nerves sending messages to their muscles
causing paralysis and loss of bodily
function
blistering agents come in gas aerosol or
liquid form and can cause the skin to
blister an example being mustard gas
choking agents like chlorine cause
respiratory failure if they're inhaled
or digested and blood agents like
hydrogen chloride affect the body's
ability to send oxygen through the
bloodstream biological weapons or
bioweapons are ones that deliberately
spread viruses bacteria or toxins in
order to cause death or harm such as
anthrax
the harmful use of chemicals in combat
or assassinations is nothing new
chemical weapons have been used by
germany in world war one the u.s in the
vietnam war and by iraq in the iran iraq
war of the 1980s this wouldn't be the
first time the kremlin has used chemical
weapons on foreign soil the most
prolific example was in syria where
russia fought alongside bashar
al-assad's government forces in the
country's civil war studies estimate
there were 85 chemical weapons attacks
russia has also repeatedly used
chemicals to poison wanted individuals
in 2018 moscow was accused of using
novichok a nerve agent in salisbury this
is a nerve agent novichok that was
developed by russia that has been stored
by russia illegally and has now been
used against a former russian agent who
was identified specifically by the
kremlin as the legitimate target of uh
of revenge and retaliation the same
agent was used on russian opposition
leader alexei navalny two years later
eight countries declared chemical
weapons stockpiles when they joined the
chemical weapons convention those
countries are albania india iraq libya
syria the united states russia and an
anonymous state widely believed to be
south korea russia declared the largest
stockpile with approximately 40 000
metric tons the amount of russia's
remaining chemical weaponry is hard to
quantify
[Music]
the short answer is yes the devastating
use of chemical weapons in world war one
prompted worldwide efforts to curb their
use and production
russia is signed up to the 1997 chemical
weapons convention which bans it from
developing using or stockpiling chemical
weapons
they're still known to have used them
if you want to know russia's plans look
at what russia accuses others of western
allies have accused putin of planning a
false flag operation that is using a
false claim that ukraine has chemical
weapons as an excuse for russia to
deploy their own the stuff that you're
hearing about
chemical weapons this is straight out of
their playbook they start saying that
there are chemical weapons that have
been stored by
their opponents or by the americans and
so when they themselves deploy uh
chemical weapons as i as i fear they
they may they have us a a sort of a mask
erotica of a fake story however some
experts have said that russia's
collaboration with the chemical weapons
convention means it wouldn't have the
capacity to launch chemical attacks such
as the nerve agent attacks seen in syria
russia could be producing chemical
weapons on a smaller scale akin to
terrorism as seen in the novichok nerve
agent attacks they're believed to have
carried out well the soviet union had
the world's largest chemical weapons and
biological weapons program in total
violation of the chemical and biological
weapons conventions these weapons are
prohibited with little sign of
politicians reaching peaceful
negotiation
hopes that tensions won't be escalated
by chemical weapons
are widely shared